みんな、みん…
みんな、あけましておめでとうございます
はじめしゃちょーです
はい、というわけで新年一発目の動画なんですけども…
特に何もしません
いや、何もしませんっていうか
ちょっとね・・・
あの・・・
お正月って気分じゃないんですよ
いや、皆さんはいいんですよ
皆さんはお正月気分でワイワイどんどんやっていただいていいんですけども
ちょっとね・・・
（鼻水を吸う音）
いよいよ卒業がかかってきまして
卒業論文書こうと思ってたんですけども
ちょっと実は紅白の方に出てまして
ちょっと見に行ってたくらいでチラチラ写ってたくらいなんですけども
うん、まあ
卒論書けなくてもね
とてもいい年末を送れたと思います
良かった良かった
良くない！
本当に良くない、このままいくと卒業出来ないくらいなんで
もう明日、明後日本当に卒論の期間なんですよ
ちょっと動画を出せない期間にはいるかもしれません
大事です・・・というわけで今年の目標を言おうかなと思いまして
3つ、ちょっと今年の目標を掲げたいなと思います
1つ目！卒業論文を終わる
しっかり学生であるべき・・・
学生
学生だからね学生としてしべき・・・
・・・もー
学生としてやるべきことをしっかりやります今年は
もうそんな長くないと思うんで・・・
あ、俺の命じゃないからね
学生生活の話よ
もうそんな長くないのでちゃんとやるべきことをやって
ちゃんんとね、学生を終えればと・・・
2つ目
もうないかもしれない
ごめんねーもう頭の中が卒論でいっぱいだからさ
あの、編集技術を磨く
これにしよう、もういままで通り動画を楽しく出すのは当たり前なのでそこはよしとして
もうちょっと動画のレベルを上げていけたらなと思います
上がるかどうかわからないけど勉強できればなと・・・
3つ目は・・・
（鼻をかむ音）
えーなんかないかな
3つ目でしょ？
えー
どうしよどうしよ
あ、そうだ決めた
俺決めたわ
部屋の掃除をしよう
今年の目標は決まった！
あー待って片付けられないな
掃除はやめとこ
待ってどうしよ！なんかないかな
今年の目標でしょ？あ、みんなに決めてもらおう
この動画のコメント欄で・・・
僕の今年も目標を一つ決めて下さい
本当に選ぶからね
皆さんのコメントの中から今年の目標選ぶんで
それを今年の目標にします
というわけでバタバタした
年明けなんですけども
お前らマジ卒業したら見とけよ
俺が世界を変えてやるからな！
というわけで今年も！楽しく適当にゆるく
よろしくお願いします
2016年もよろしくお願いします
じゃあな！